the Mona Lisa one of the most famous
portraits in the world Leonardo da Vinci
painted his masterpiece in the early
16th century her mysterious glance and
enigmatic smile still fascinate us the
Mona Lisa from Leonardo da Vinci the
Mona Lisa is a superstar among the
world's masterpieces no other work has
been viewed so often reproduced so many
times or inspired so many people
desperate science fella cannot sleep and
even today the Mona Lisa continues to
inspire new art new york artist james
ritzy turned her into a pop art star or
her inexplicable charm in buttons and
beads as captured by british artist jane
perkins an abstract interpretation by
mark evans using only her colors and
canadian artist Bradley Hart injected
paint into bubble wrap to create a
gently pixelated portrait
the original is on show in Paris it's
been on permanent display in the Louvre
for more than 200 years Mona Lisa lives
on the first floor in room 6 of the
denim wing protected by a thick pane of
bulletproof glass if we imagine it as a
corn silk mo the Mona Lisa is the one
painting in the Louvre that everyone
wants to see every day between 20 and 30
thousand sometimes 50,000 people come to
see her or at least try to see her with
50,000 visitors you have to be pretty
patient try and get a close look at
portions she do
Leonardo da Vinci spent more than 3
years painting portraits of the young
woman art historians still don't know
exactly who she was her contours are
soft and undefined da Vinci called this
technique sfumato which means in the
manner of smoke her eyes seem to follow
the viewer her smile is but the gentlest
suggestion her hands they patiently one
on top of the other
Liana Casas a technique big jihad da
Vinci's brilliant technique and his
ability to contrast light and dark lend
the piece like Mona Lisa sits upright
you get the sense she's about to smile
or the opposite that she's closing her
mouth we don't know but one sense is
that she might want to say something
again communication her secret smile is
timeless and Mona Lisa has become a
modern icon of Western art her face
never goes out of style
in 1911 the painting was stolen
the theft made headlines around the
world there's a corner to joy because
the Mona Lisa was always famous
but after it was stolen people started
reproducing her image all around the
world that had the fortunate effect of
introducing her to more people than ever
before
Sakuni sauce or by datalogger poutine
if a picture is worth a thousand words
there is definitely money to be made
with the Mona Lisa ad agencies use her
likeness to promote products and
services ELCA clink Homer is chief
creative officer at McCann Erickson
advertising she believes the icon is
still an eye-catcher
but the idea has to be original and
creative Lisa is still a great face for
marketing not because of her beauty or
any particular attribute but because of
the way she's portrayed it's a small
painting that has a powerful effect like
a secret that wants to be unveiled it's
a great image to work with them quite
apart from her innocence and modesty
hiding hide or don't wooden facade hide
had a fine art shipper a dating service
a postal operator Mona Lisa's face has
graced it all she's a celebrity with
star power all over the world but she's
never given up her mystery
Damona Lisa on Gibson and a mug shot she
has a mystical the secret aura to this
day people still don't know who she is
or why she was portrayed that's why
she's so compelling the top of event
yoga hymens I hope we never learned her
secret if we did her face wouldn't be
such a marketing drug the hope would
usually tableau she's in newspapers and
artistic reworkings and marketing it
just makes the Mona Lisa even more
fascinating that's how her portrait
became so famous the most famous one in
the world